on july 27th of last year the tigers
opening day pre-game ceremonies
represented the first opportunity at
comerica park for the franchise to
celebrate the life of one of their
all-time greats
as part of the ceremony a flag was
raised in tribute to alkaline
at this time al avila and michael k line
will place a ceremonial wreath at the
base of alkaline statue above the brick
wall in left center field
the statue which was dedicated on april
5th in the year 2000 remains a permanent
fixture in comerica park an enduring
memory of the tiger legend
casey my has got to be exciting this
this guy right here and i wish we had a
heart monitor on there right now just to
see you know he's pumped up
strikes out a rise to start the day and
start his season got a cutter or
splitter i think that was a cutter you
want to have these off speed pitchers
breaking down into the ground we're
looking at the depth there you go
that's a breaking ball
with good depth
one two another punch out for casey mize
kepler faces this shift candelario
playing shortstop basically swinging a
miss on a fastball up in the strike zone
and what a first inning for casey mines
man fantastic finished him off with the
high fastball he strikes out the side
gives up a harmless single to cruz but
no more last season for jh was a good
year obviously uh getting up there in
age the most important thing for him is
his health but he brings a wealth of
experience big game experience he's
pitched in every situation
got a long way to center field
cave looks like he's got plenty of room
and it's a scoreless first for jay ham
looking for a hole on the right side and
still
jonathan scope retires nelson cruz and
casey mize retires the twins one two
three in the third
now you're behind you got to protect
to left field that's going to get down
and all the way to the wall
that's a one-out double for nico goodram
his first extra base hit of the season
tigers have their first hit of the day
so you can go a little bit higher a
little bit more inside or you can even
go something soft down and away it looks
like they're going to go change up
down and away
check swing
and cabrera asked for the appeal and
didn't like the answer it was cabrera
before
kerwin danley appealing to c.b buchner
and then
buckner went ahead and rang him up
anyway a strikeout stranding good room
at third base and we head to the fourth
scoreless
kepler driving into the gap in left
center field he's got another extra base
hit and another opposite field hit we
saw the rbi in the last game in
milwaukee flipped the curveball to left
and drove in a couple runs there
let's see what he gets
3-2 swung on it miss that fastball was
at 97 baby a little extra to get on top
of that it was quick wouldn't it
checked his swing and there's ball four
first and second
with one down
the payoff
and a ground ball backhand stabbed by
scope one out at second and safe at
first there's there's where the shift
gets you
to center down for a hit the man just
keeps on hitting
kepler scores the first run of the game
the fifth game this year where the twins
have scored first he's an aggressive
hitter
at the same time you don't want to walk
him you understand he's aggressive so
you try and entice him to swinging at
your pitch as opposed to going up there
and giving him something to hit
and jeffers takes a walk and the bases
are filled now for luisa eyes
ninth pitch of the ad bat coming here
drives one to center
jones is tracking it
and he's got it shy of the wall
twins leave them loaded
casey mize showing some toughness to get
through that at-bat and that inning
and he draws the logo to lead off the
fourth
[Applause]
and 90 down the middle gets a swing and
a miss one away 271 lifetime hitter from
the right side of the plate is robbie
grossman
slams one to left center that's gonna
find a gap
he's gonna score
they're waving him home
[Music]
the throw is not in time
an rbi double from robbie grossman an
exclamation point on his first tigers
hit and it ties it at one 0-2 to the
tigers second baseman
[Music]
and
c.b buckner said he went looked like the
pitch was a strike to begin with scope
is gone out number two
and it is target there jeffers wanted a
high fastball and got it and got strike
three the tigers got the tying run in
their half of the fourth
good room
to right field for his second beat of
the day
[Applause]
3-1 a rope to right center
goodrum's going to score cabrera hustles
to third candelario gets greedy he's got
a run-scoring double and the tigers have
their first lead of the day
that's a great example how it's done
here's the one two grossman
on a line to right
in front of kepler one run is home and
they'll hold up
candelario with third
robbie grossman coming through in the
clutch again here in the fifth rocket
right there hit the ball too hard
we know what the requirements are
he went too far
and snow strikes out
he got him yeah it was worth the wait
sure was
michael fulmer comes back strong after
the lead-off double a couple of
strikeouts and he keeps it right where
it was this is an important at bat right
here you know twins have been kind of
flat a little bit in this game and
sometimes the opposing pitcher has a lot
to do with that
high fly right center field and deep
going back to the wall that ball is gone
nelson cruz again
his third home run of the year
and the twins are within a run yeah he
went to the well one more time thought
he could beat him with 96 at the top of
the zone and nelson cruz being the
veteran he is made the adjustment just
took that barrel of the ball and hit the
right part of the ball park
buxon with a high blast to left field we
are tied
byron buxton
with a home run
to even the score at three
well he looks like he's feeling just
fine he took the first half of this game
off and
comes in a huge swing right there tried
to fastball up in the zone and hit it
almost as far as crews hit that ball
yesterday
new ball game right here
sharply hit nicely speared by candelario
and he makes an accurate throw to first
good d
really good d and really good inning for
gregory soto
the other way for his third hit of the
day
[Applause]
crowd giving him the juice
grounds it through the left side for a
base hit
tigers have a couple of men on with one
down here in the ninth
another o2
grounded to third hasta dio to second
for one the relay
in time to get cabrera and force extra
innings
here we go
another payoff
sits him down
what a job by gregory soto
and his defense in the 10th the threat
was there squashed
by the power lefty we see a frozen rope
down the right field line
2-1
just like that
the hollywood script continues
akil badu wears a crown to give the
tigers the win
this is some kind of awesome isn't it
every day you learn something about a
player a manager
a city
and right here today aj hinch
showed that he's ready for battle
he told everybody to get ready and he
used them all and he went for it and the
payoff
came through